A fellow knitter, Carmen, wants to knit
a cardigan with curved front edges.
Now, unlike diagonal shaping,
where you can use the magic formula,
there really isn't a mathematical formula
that can be used to create a deep curve.
Here's a no math solution.
Print out some knitter's graph paper,
preferably to-scale
graph paper, at your gauge.
Carmen's working at a gauge of 16 stitches
and 24 rows, so I created that size
paper from the Knit It Now tool.
I've marked off 6 by 6 inches on the grid.
Now, using to scale graph paper will
really help you visualize the size
of the curve and see if
that will work for your sweater.
Next, use a compass or a plate or just
wing it and draw a curve
between these two lines.
I suggest making two of these and cut one
out and hold it up to see if the width
and the depth work for your design.
Now, notice where the curve is
intersecting the grid lines.
We'll establish our shaping
based on these points.
Remember, each square represents
one stitch and one row.
Use a pencil and start drawing a zigzag
line across the stitches and rows
following the curve.
This doesn't have to be perfect.
Can you see how this is creating a nice,
graceful curve following
along stitches and rows?
Here's something to consider when
you plan your actual knitting.
You'll be increasing stitches every row
and every other row,
so you want to consider where you're going
to place these increases depending on how
you're going to finish
the edge of your sweater.
In other words,
do you want to work the increases
on the very edge stitches
or one or two stitches in from the edge?
Practice a bit to see what you
prefer before starting your garment.